a fiery prophecy zombie pilgrims and a
poisoned poisoner Wednesday ended with
such a bang that you may have missed how
the pieces fit together
everything happening in the explosive
finale of Wednesday is tied to a
maniacal colonizer who founded the
village of Jericho named Joseph
crackstone he's a vile and devious man
who hates outcasts even though the
outcasts lived in this part of North
America before he and his ilk ever
arrived there he wants to eradicate them
from the face of the Earth his Prejudice
sets the stage for the show's
exploration of bigotry through a
Fantastical lens one of those outcasts
is an ancestor of Wednesday Adams who
also happens to look exactly like her
named goodie Adams her family is killed
by crack Stone but she escapes in Val's
Vengeance she kills crack Stone curses
his soul and puts him in a casket sealed
with a blood lock to keep him from ever
returning
when Wednesday first visits Jericho
Sheriff Donovan tells her exactly what
he thinks of her father the man belongs
Behind Bars from murder
upon further investigation Wednesday
discovers that when her parents were
students at Nevermore Gomez was accused
of killing an army named Garrett Gates
the truth is that Garrett was a
descendant of Joseph crackstone tasked
with killing everyone at Nevermore with
Nightshade poisoning however Garrett was
so obsessed with Morticia that he tried
to kill Gomez so that he could have her
during their altercation of Isle of
nightshade poison shattered in his
pocket killing him
following the death of Garrett his
sister Laurel flees the country and is
believed to have drowned later on
however Laurel Gates fakes her death
like the rest of her family she hates
outcasts and can't stand the fact that
they built a school for them on her
ancestors land and killed her brother so
Laurel builds a new identity Marilyn
Thornhill she returns to Jericho and
manages to secure a teaching position at
Nevermore the school sees having a
normie on the staff as a first step in
bringing outcasts and normies together
but it's all a ruse thornhill's Mission
from the very beginning is to resurrect
her Fallen ancestor and allow him to
finish his work this line of thinking is
reminiscent to Modern racists who preach
the virtues of the good old days but
Thornhill takes it to the extreme by
literally bringing someone from the old
days back to achieve his bigoted goals
typically I have great admiration for
well-executed Revenge plots but yours
was a bit extreme
the ending of the season was prophesized
around the same time Morticia and Gomez
attended Nevermore a fellow student who
is a powerful Seer has a vision of the
school Bernie she recreates the image in
a book that is locked away in a library
hidden in the lower regions of Nevermore
it depicts a pilgrim battling a
pigtailed young girl a student is so
convinced that the girl in the picture
will destroy the school that she
eventually orders her son Rowan to kill
her if he sees her as it turns out
though psychic Visions aren't the most
reliable when it comes to seeing the
future we do see Wednesday confronting a
pilgrim but she isn't there to destroy
the school she's saving it this again
plays into the idea that the way we see
the world can be obscured by our biases
as Morticia informs Wednesday psychic
Visions are personalized if you're
optimistic or a dove you see happy
Visions if you're pessimistic or a raven
you see Doom and Gloom the woman who
prophesies the final battle must have
been a raven because she assumed
disaster was coming when it was actually
salvation
Nevermore was created to be a safe haven
where outcasts can learn and socialize
without the fear of being discriminated
against of course if you put enough
people together clicks and social groups
start to form such as the case when
Wednesday arrives while everyone there
is considered to be strange and
different they still more or less
interact the way normies do Wednesday is
too weird even for them that doesn't
mean she's incapable of making friends
however she eventually finds a group of
her own her roommate Enid is a werewolf
who can't transform Eugene spends all
his time with bees and has zero friends
Xavier grew up rich with a famous father
but he's nothing like him even Bianca
the coolest of the cool kids doesn't
quite fit in because she's a siren her
voice can control people so she never
knows that the people around her
genuinely like her or are compelled by
her boys to do what she says this
unifies them and helps create the
perfect team to stand up the Thornhill
and crack Stone
we eventually learned that goody Adams
founded a secret society known as the
nightshades in the early days of
Nevermore to protect outcasts from
vindictive normies Wednesday discovers
the location of their headquarters by
matching the watermark on the drawing of
the prophecy when the statue of Edgar
Allan Poe and solving riddle as it turns
out the society still exists and they
invite Wednesday to join them she
declines because even a secret society
is too social for her still the fact
that she was able to discover them earns
her some points they don't all become
her friends exactly but when she informs
them of the fight that is about to take
place they stand with her to protect
Nevermore and outcasts in general
when Wednesday arrives at Nevermore
there's a monster killing people the
sheriff has been telling everyone it's a
bear but Bears don't remove body parts
and leave with them tell the bear attack
you don't really believe that share no I
don't
through her investigation Wednesday
discovers the monster is called a hide
these beasts are human but transform
when triggered by dramatic events or
chemical injections the identity of the
Hide is the main mystery carrying the
series hides are tied to the people who
liberate them considering them to be
their masters Thornhill knows this and
she also knows that the sheriff's son
Tyler is a hide following the death of
his mother Thornhill manipulates him and
becomes a surrogate parental figure she
then chains him to a cave injects him
with her Elixir and forces him to
transform into a hide to kill people and
steal their body parts to help her
resurrect crackstone
like many of the characters in the show
Wednesday's perky and colorful roommate
Enid is at war with herself on the one
hand she seems to get along with most of
the kids at school and always has a
sunny disposition but she's incapable of
wolfing out and is ashamed of that for
most of the show The mosa changes is her
nails she's worried that her inability
to transform will lead to her family
disowning her if she isn't part of a
pack werewolf's Society will shun her
and she will die alone this fear drives
most of her decisions however things
start to change when she stands up to
her mother and proclaims she is her own
person from that point on she stops
operating out of fear and begins acting
out of love during the blood moon when
Nevermore is under attack she finally
Wolves Out subduing Tyler in his hide
form and protecting Wednesday
[Music]
the Severus Snape in this Harry Potter
Prestige is principal Weems although she
is a major antagonist in the series she
isn't the villain viewers are led to
think she'd be upon first encountering
her in fact every decision she makes was
meant to protect Wednesday Nevermore an
outcasts in general she wants to make
sure outcasts are never seen as evil or
dangerous so they would be accepted by
normies what's so tragic about this is
the fact that her memories of Nevermore
aren't the rosiest while Morticia and
Gomez remember Nevermore being the
greatest years of their lives she
recalls mostly disappointment and
loneliness such good times we had didn't
we Larissa
some of us better than others
she has every reason to be the villain
but she sees the good in people and that
drives her to always do what she
believes is the right thing yes
Wednesday and her friends save the
school from Thornhill and crack Stone
but Weems dedicates her life to
protecting Nevermore and that makes her
a true hero
Eugene is a stereotypical nerd who is so
isolated from his peers that the mere
fact that his classmates are willing to
visit his beekeeping Sanctuary makes him
so excited he essentially pledges his
life to them it would be easy to write
him off as desperate for companionship
but it's a little more complicated than
that Eugene doesn't just help Wednesday
with her investigation because he wants
a friend he does so because he believes
in his own fuzzy moral code
snitches get stung it's Hive code
basically Eugene understands that every
bee in a hive works together to Serve
and Protect the queen he's so in tune
with these creatures that he adapts
their social structure to his own life
during the PO cup Wednesday has a vision
when touching Joseph crackstone's Crypt
in it she is visited by her ancestor
goody who tells her
you might think that this is a metaphor
but nope it's literal after all goody
trapped cracked Stone's body in a casket
sealed with a blood lock as Thornhill
explains in the final episode the only
way to open it is to Spill the blood of
an atoms on the night of a Blood Moon
Thornhill sacrifices Wednesday and
successfully resurrects crackstone
however that's not the only key goodie
was talking about Wednesday is also the
only person who can Vanquish crack stone
for Good by stabbing him in his heart as
she lies there dying the spirit of goody
passes through her thanks to her
necklace and heals her wounds freeing
her to face crack Stone and end his
reign of terror forever
the town of Jericho serves as a visual
metaphor for the division happening in
the series it's a quaint Town built on
Stolen land with a massive School meant
for outcasts looming over it although
the money Nevermore brings into the town
keeps it thriving the citizens there
hate the fact that weirdos are living on
their land they have an amusement park
called Pilgrim world that teaches people
all about the early days of the Town
settlement it is mentioned in the series
itself that this worship of pilgrims
ignores the genocide of native people
and whitewashes history Beyond paying
lip service to this however the show
examines this dichotomy through a visual
metaphor by aligning themselves with the
idealized and inaccurate depictions of
pilgrims the town of Jericho makes a
clear statement that they believe
natives don't deserve to exist on their
land the land Nevermore was built on
didn't belong to Joseph crackstone it
was reclaimed by the outcasts he tried
to annihilate the final showdown between
Wednesday and crack Stone seems like an
intentional comment on colonization as
it is literally the descendant of a long
line of outcasts Wednesday who battles
an actual colonizer crackstone
in the end we find out Tyler was the
hide learned that Thornhill was
controlling him and finally see
crackstone destroyed also Wednesday
learns the importance of hugging she
even accepts a dreaded cell phone to
stay in touch with everyone it seems
like everything is wrapped up nice and
neat until the final scene as paramedics
transport Tyler to the hospital he
begins transforming into hide form
suggesting that we haven't seen the end
of him additionally there is still the
question of Wednesday's stalker when
examining a music box found in Laurel
Gates's room she finds a secret
compartment with photos of herself
clearly someone has been following her
and taking snapshots the easy assumption
is that it was Miss Thornhill but if
that's the case why does Wednesday get
text messages from an unknown number on
her new phone from a number she doesn't
recognize beyond that why do those
messages contain new photos of Wednesday
presumably this mystery will be solved
in a potential season 2.
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]